До Петра Хабаренка завітав клієнт.
"Тут така справа… Хочу узбережжя забудувати" -
простягає Хабаренку хрумкий пакет.
А Хабаренко - чому й ні? Гроші - лівою, підпис - правою…
Аж раптом за спиною клієнта намальовуються здорованІ,
і виявляється, що клієнт - не клієнт,
а агент НАБУ!
Що має відбутися із Хабаренком далі?
Слідство проти Хабаренка веде Національне антикорупційне бюро України.
Воно створене для викриття та розслідування
корупції на вищих щаблях влади:
серед міністрів, депутатів, суддів, прокурорів.
Взагалі-то Хабаренка вже й раніше
можна було запідозрити в корупції.
Помітити це могло Національне агентство
з питань запобігання корупції,
воно має перевіряти електронні декларації високопосадовців
та моніторити спосіб життя чиновників.
А в разі підозри - передавати інформацію НАБУ.
Для повноцінної слідчої роботи детективам НАБУ
також потрібне право самостійно прослуховувати розмови підозрюваних
і писати слідчі запити за кордон,
куди виводять гроші корупціонери на кшталт Хабаренка.
Утім,  Генпрокуратура, яку очолює людина президента,
воліла б не надавати НАБУ таких повноважень.
Незалежним підрозділом в структурі ГПУ
є Спеціалізована антикорупційна прокуратура (САП).
Це ще одна ланка антикорупційної системи.
САП має перевіряти розслідування, які веде НАБУ,
і представляти звинувачення в суді.
Поки що справи Хабаренка та інших корупціонерів
опиняються у звичайних судах,
які всіляко гальмують їхній розгляд.
У 40% резонансних справ, які НАБУ передало в суди,
ще навіть не відбулося підготовчого засідання.
еякі з них припадають пилом у судах вже понад рік.
Саме тому вкрай потрібен Вищий антикорупційний суд,
який незалежно і оперативно
розгляне справу Хабаренка.
Утім, ця ланка антикорупційної системи
все ще не запрацювала.
Таких, як Хабаренко, чимало в коридорах влади,
і вони всіляко гальмують  створення
незалежного антикорупційного суду.
Але без нього система боротьби з корупцією в Україні
не запрацює повноцінно. Лише тоді Хабаренко
й інші корупціонери у владі опиняться за ґратами.